so sieht das diese woche eigentlich auch
gespürt dieses überwältigende ja
magische gefühl der gleichgültigkeit
richtig dienstag war wieder tag der
deutschen einheit
blödes timing so kurz nach der schock
war hier noch mal die verteilung der afg
wähler das dunkelblaue erinnern mich von
der form an diesen einen start den wir
früher hatten wir immer der eine mag ich
komme ich drauf man fragt sich schon
seit dieser wahl wie viel einheit ist da
wirklich noch
tschuldigung hin zumindest beim wählen
sind wir offensichtlich gespalten klar
und bei den löhnen und bei der rente und
beim vermögen aber sonst läuft super
gefeiert wurde der tag der einer diesmal
in mainz für die kanzlerin eine prima
gelegenheit endlich mal zu chillen
so wie bei jeder einheitsfeier dem
sogenannten establishment zudem
wahlweise jeder gezählt wird oder
enthüllen könnte der ihre misserfolge
und verführt ein vereintes
demokratisches deutschland
jedes jahr
da da hatte wohl jemand besuch vom ost
sandmännchen war er kommt schlaf ist
eine ganz normale menschliche reaktion
vor allem auf frank walter steinmeier
und jetzt sind im westen haben sie
verfolgt natürlich wieder alle
stinksauer auf die bösen ossis so lange
die nur motzen ist uns egal aber jetzt
wählen die auch noch was sie wollen nach
all den schicken neuen hausfassaden die
wir den spendiert haben und die
ostdeutsche bevölkerung sollte das auch
honorieren und bessere wahlergebnisse
abgeben hier kann ja nicht mal richtig
wählen
so kriegt dann die wahl zurück mit allen
fehlern über angestrichen haben
dabei hatten wir denen doch extra eine
eigene partei geschenk damals diese
ulkige pds oder wie die hieß damit
konnte man nichts kaputt machen
wir sind insgesamt echt enttäuscht von
diesen undankbaren leuten wie viele
ostdeutsche kennen sie
eigentlich und die reichten
das
das ist diese berühmte westdeutsche
herzlichkeit um die uns die ganze welt
beneidet über 20 afd im osten die nation
leidet quasi unter einer
posttraumatischen belastungsstörung
jetzt im nachhinein nach all den
jahrzehnten sagen viele experten es war
irrsinn die komplette ddr industrie zu
zerschlagen damals im osten sitzt ja
nicht mal ein dax-unternehmen und
hochspannend ist übrigens auch wer den
osten regiert im jahr 2017
bei den fünf ministerpräsidenten sieht
es noch gut aus
da ist nur ein wessi dabei den stellen
wir hier mal ja den stelle jemand
symbolisch als weiß wo ist da die ossis
sind natürlich beim namen ist ja logisch
so aber bei den staatssekretären in den
neuen ländern sind schon die hälfte aus
dem westen so von den 200
abteilungsleitern der ostdeutschen
ministerien sind es drei viertel freunde
wessis und im bundeskabinett sitzt genau
eine ministerin aus dem osten die frau
wanka eine bildungsministerin also nicht
mein richtiges ministerium ein ossi ein
ossi ja merkel ist in hamburg geboren
die zählt nicht komisch woher kommt nur
dieses minderwertigkeitsgefühle
ostdeutschen versteht man gar nicht klar
die afd ist die letzte partei die in den
neuen ländern irgendwas besser macht ich
sag nur infrastruktur auf dem land
katastrophe und da ist das das einzige
telefon und es geht
womit man wirklich mal ein notruf
betätigen können ansonsten jahre hier
und da gestellte böse wirklich störte
hose es ist so selbst die traurigsten
sachen klingen lustig auf sächsisch